hey guys this is Inka and for the next
24 hours I will only be making and
eating tic toc recipes I recently
started using tic toc and there is just
a world of content on this app tons of
really interesting videos every day that
pop up on my For You page hashtag FIP
including like cute pet content a lot of
Animal Crossing stuff a lot of food
content even just hash tag cooking alone
has twelve point three billion views the
best part is not only are there recipes
but there's also like a bunch of really
fun hacks that I think could be cool to
test out so I was thinking I could do a
24 hour cooking challenge using only the
recipes that I find on my 4u page this
is going to be an adventure let's get
started with breakfast so to start the
day off I really want to try making this
pancake cereal that has been popping up
over and over again on my page I think
I've seen at least like 10 videos so I
feel like that's a sign that I should do
it it is basically tiny pancakes around
this size you cook a lot of them all at
once then you put them in a bowl and
drizzle syrup over it the most important
thing is really just some pancake mix I
just need some milk and eggs so let me
whip up my pancake batter a cup of
pancake mix 1/2 a cup of milk egg whisk
this up I think we are good to go the
next step is to put it in some sort of
container so we can squeeze it out onto
the pan I am just going to go the
traditional route of putting it in a
ziploc bag now to fry them up melted
some butter okay this might get messy
[Music]
it's a little messy looking but this is
what my pancakes look like right now
they said that the trick is to
essentially leave it in the pan for a
little longer so it gets crispy on the
bottom whoo-hoo this is my little bowl
of pancake cereal pretty cute smells
really good smells just like pancake but
before I add the serpent I am also going
to make a drink to go with it and I know
you guys have already seen me do the
detail gonna coffee but I found this
really cool trick on tik-tok where
instead of using a electric whisk you
can just spin your whisk between your
hands and that is a much faster way to
get to that consistency we want there's
only been a minute you can already see
that like frothy consistency that took
me forever to whip up last time amazing
now that I have my coffee I'm gonna put
this over a glass of milk and I should
be able to eat my cereal and my coffee
look at how tiny these pieces are which
I Oh
I'm not only a big fan of like tiny food
like this it looks super cute and since
we're eating it like cereal only makes
sense that I'm eating a lot in one bite
right it's just like eating pancake I
love the crisp at the bottom I do feel
like they're slightly drier really kids
would love this I'm gonna add a little
bit of milk right now to try it before
it gets too soggy the leftover maple
syrup has kind of blended in with the
milk and the pancake kind of soaked it
up right away now I feel a little bit
like I'm eating dessert for breakfast
but what's not to like about that
this combo is pretty much perfect this
new technique saved me a lot of time
think it's a great way to enjoy a cafe
ish drink at home and these pencils are
just really fun to enjoy I think the
first meal started off pretty well I'm
going to go do some work now and then I
will see you guys again for lunch
it is now 12:12 p.m. and I know I had
breakfast not too long ago but I am
already ready to make lunch also happens
when I'm working at home I guess I just
I'm always thinking about food alright
so for this meal I am going to make the
really popular one pan egg sandwich
just like the packaged cereal I feel
like it has been popping up again and
again where you make the entire sandwich
in the pan it looks like it only takes
maybe like 2 minutes so I wanted to try
this out to make things a little more
exciting I am also going to add another
recipe that I found where she makes
these carrot bacon it looked really good
and she has some amazing recipes on her
page this one popped up on my feet and I
just remember being so mind blown by it
I just had to try we're gonna do a
carrot bacon egg sandwich first things
first
carrot bacon we have some carrots here
the maple syrup liquid smoke garlic
powder onion powder paprika I think she
wanted smoked paprika but this is the
only one I had first step is to shave
our carrots this was around 2 carrots
but I have a bunch of carrot strips here
they kind of already do look like bacon
I'm just going to make the marinade
there weren't any specific measurements
for this so I am going to eyeball it
this smells super strong I guess this is
what makes it taste like bacon this it
gets stir I'm also going to add in some
salt is a very nice sort of reddish
brown a lot of flavor in there right now
so I'm gonna go ahead and put my carrots
and mix it up I'm gonna leave it in for
2 minutes and then I can put it in the
airfryer go now we wait it's done it's
done I heard it beep it smells so good
he's heard what my strips look like now
this is really good the flavor is
exactly like a bacon it's like a flavor
bomb now that I have my bacon done I can
go into making the actual egg sandwich
it looks super promising though for the
egg sandwich you really only need three
base things two slices of bread I'm
using brioche two eggs some butter I saw
that a lot of people also put into
toppings they liked so I'm also putting
in some sharp white cheddar and of
course my beautiful bacon melting my
butter
in the pan crack these eggs and beat
them up add in my eggs I'm just going to
dip the bread in like this you're gonna
flip it around same thing with this
butter splice once the egg has cooked on
the other side I'm gonna flip it around
but it's pretty cool how everything just
happens in the pan through the little
flip flip fold it in add my cheese
speaking fold it in just pressing it
down a little bit to make sure the
cheese is all melted this is almost done
now so I am going to plate it up lunch
is finally done this is what I have here
I try to toast it a little bit more you
can see this carrot bacon in there and
also the egg and melted cheese it smells
like french toast without the cinnamon
there's a lot of melted goodness in here
I was gonna make a drink but everything
I saw on my page was alcoholic and I
still need to work so I am just sticking
to water for now it's like a hot pocket
that carrot is really good Wow I'm not
somebody who likes carrots very much
usually but when they're cooked like
this I feel like I could eat tons the
texture is a little bit different but
the flavor is on point I feel like the
sandwich idea in itself is really good
but the carrot bacon really takes it to
that next level if I hadn't seen it on
tik-tok I probably would have never
known I think these two recipes are
really worth trying I'm gonna go ahead
and finish my sandwich and then do some
more work maybe do some exercises too
eventually we'll get to dinner I'm
pretty full it's been a couple of hours
it's still really bright outside because
the Sun has been setting at like around
8:00 p.m. lately for dinner tonight I am
gonna be testing out three different
recipes that I found on tick tock it's
going to take a while so I am starting a
little bit earlier one dish will be my
side dish slash appetizer one dish will
be my main course and then one will be
my drink and I'm super excited about
these three recipes because these are
the ones that popped up on my 4u page
and then I actually saved and bookmarked
them as
that I really wanted to try who started
off I am going to be frying up some rice
paper this video I found was super
awesome it was basically a tutorial on
like the different hacks that you could
do with rice paper and the first hack
she did was actually to deep-fry these
so then they become these really poofy
rice chips and they looked really good
they remind me of the shrimp crackers
that I had growing up so I am going to
give that a test I'm just going to heat
up some oil and while that's heating up
I'm gonna cut up my rice paper into
smaller pieces I almost look like
playing cards they should expand once
they hit the oil oil is getting pretty
hot the second they hit the oil it just
expands it's like watching a flower
bloom right in front of you look at this
from that texture earlier to this wholly
puffed up here that crisp truly
incredible this is one of those things
that just looks amazing even as you're
watching it being made I'm gonna salt it
really quick so excited for this already
and as for my main course I'm actually
going to be making some a dumpling of
fried rice this dish was created by chef
Chris who has some pretty awesome videos
on his tik-tok page lots of really good
Korean recipes and a lot of them
actually popped up on my feet so I
really wanted to give this one a shot
because it sounds kind of bizarre at
first and then you see the end product
which looks so good and also if you
think about it kind of makes sense so
the first thing you need are some
dumplings scallions sesame oil soy sauce
salt and of course some rice which I
already have first things first I'm
gonna cut up my scallions now to cut up
my dumplings that looks like bite-sized
pieces I have my
walk here toss in the scallions add in
my frozen dumplings I did a little bit
more oil so I can put in the eggs now
we're gonna mix it off together
it smells like some flames in here it
just doesn't look like the dumplings we
know he also said to add 1 to 1 ratio
dumpling to rice so I'm using the same
bowl I put the dumplings to put my rice
dump it on there Oh
put some sesame oil on there soy sauce
mix it up smells really good
hear that like beautiful crackling sound
thanks so right now I have my appetizer
done I have my fried rice done the last
thing to do would be to make my drink
since it's the end of the day now I
figured I can finally try one that has a
bit of booze in it I remember liking
this video when I came up on my feed
because it just had ice cream and soda
and a bit of alcohol and it really just
came out like a really good slushy /
milkshake so I am super pumped to
finally be able to try it the original
video actually used like melon /
honeydew flavor but I am going to swap
everything out for strawberry since that
is my preferred flavor everything else
all my steps will be exactly the same
you need three things some soda this
brand specifically dessert bars and of
course soju and then all you have to do
is grab a blender add some ice grape off
the ice cream into the cup now I'm going
to add in my soda
adds in some alcohol cover it up and
blend it wow it has a very thick
consistency it smells like strawberry
candy great okay I have everything it is
time to eat this actually looks
incredible over here I have my dumpling
fried rice I put an egg on top that's
what it looks like underneath you can't
really see the dumplings anymore these
beautiful crispy rice paper chips and
then my three ingredient slushy it has
been a long day and
I'm exhausted I'm gonna actually take a
sip of this drink Cheers
who is this dangerous because you can
barely taste the alcohol in it it is
just a very light and I feel like
summery drink now I'm gonna try my chips
they are so thin I can see the light
through them I think these would go so
well with just about anything the
perfect snack to make now for the thing
I've been looking forward to the most
big bite that is so good Wow
I guess it does make sense right because
the dumplings have already been seasons
or there is meat and vegetables in there
for those of you who are thinking like
why don't I just eat the dumplings as is
mixing it with the fried rice it almost
like doubles the amount and the thing is
the rice soaks up some of that dumpling
flavor so every bite is super flavorful
this is definitely something I would be
making again I am going to very happily
enjoy the rest of my dinner I knew there
was a reason why I saved these you guys
are incredible and I am so glad I am on
this app because I found y'all this
marks the end of my 24-hour tick-tock
recipe challenge I really do look
forward to trying out even more recipes
as they pop up on my for you page what
do you know but you can always pick up a
new skill or two I would love to know
what else you guys want to see me try
and do in terms of cooking challenges
that I will enjoy my cookie now and I
will see you guys next time
[Music]